dan is with us in Illinois hey Dan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
just I went to Xander and I'm looking at
auto insurance and it looks like I can
save a good amount of money there just
I'm good with like the deductible and
the premium and everything but I'm
looking into like the bodily injury
property damage like uninsured motorist
injury and that sort of thing and I
didn't know like what level is recommend
for that kind of stuff well the typical
live typically in the auto insurance
world the cheapest part of the policy is
the liability part of the policy so I
always recommend carrying high liability
like five hundred three hundred or
something like that because it's not the
difference in that and going cheaper on
that is very low and if you get into the
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
liability it it's seldom is seldom stops
at 100 you know or 200 so you want to
get a huh you want to get the 500 300 or
500 250 IRA which structure with that
particular company something like that
so in general in the insurance world
liability is one of the best buys it's
the least you pay for and it's a it's a
good spin as you get wealthier and you
start to say you have a net worth of
more than a half million dollars or and
or you have a large income you're
probably I'm even going to want to pick
up a liability umbrella policy to attach
to the top of your homeowners and the
top of your car insurance you can buy an
extra million dollars in liability for
those two things in an umbrella policy
for a couple hundred bucks a year in
most cases and so once again that kind
of makes my case that the liability
insurance is just not that expensive and
other than that most of the standard
coverages are fine on the other stuff
and what you're looking for is just an
apples to apples comparison what you
so that you can see if you're really
saving money and you typically will be
saving money when you use someone like a
sander that is an independent insurance
agent hey thanks for the call I
appreciate you joining us guys we talked
about this in the ads all the time but
it's good to just stop as a teaching
tool and let you understand there's two
types of insurance agents out there
there's captive agents and independent
agents captive agents work for one
company like a state farm or a
nationwide or something like that they
can only sell that company their captive
they're owned by that company in that
sense an independent insurance agent
could sell many policies for many
different companies now they can't sell
for the captive companies but what
you'll find is the independent insurance
agent that shops among several different
companies will almost always beat your
state farms and your nation wives and
that kind of thing for one thing there's
no expensive football players on their
commercials costs a lot of money to get
an NFL quarterback on your commercial
cost a lot more money to get two of them
on your commercial and just keep this in
mind that's built into your premiums
okay and State Farm is the largest
insurance company in America on property
and casualty but they are definitely not
the best I personally had trouble with
them getting to pay them Clank getting
them to pay claims people hit my car
with and they had State Farm Insurance
always go oh crap this is gonna be a
fight I'm going back to fight these
people to get my money out of them and
so that that's what you run into and so
you know you want to net and it's not
big does not mean better and more
expensive does not mean better and just
because you went to high school with the
person doesn't mean it's better okay
you're looking for an independent
insurance agent and they will shop among
the independent surance agent works for
you they get paid when they do a good
job and you buy
the other people work for the insurance
company and so that's why they call it a
State Farm agent or a nationwide agent
or an Allstate agent those are captive
companies and when you shop you'll
almost always get a better deal when you
shop against those and and many times
much better coverage even